[Musique]
anne marivin journaliste de l'équipe est
espace autochtone de radio-canada
bonjour imprécis de se retrouver à
distance comment ça vanne ma vie ça va
bien falloir travailler vous oui c'est
bien ça se passe bien quand même
pour commencer justement j'aimerais que
vous nous racontiez comment se passe le
travail à distance pour l'équipe
d'espacé doctoresse que c'est compliqué
d'entrer en contact avec les diverses
communautés à travers le pays
communauté autochtone bien sûr à travers
le pays dont comment ça se passe
alors pour l'équipe d'autres d'espèces
autochtones ça se passe bien on est
chacun chez soi on se réunit tous les
matins dans une conversation tous les
matins pour joindre les communautés
autochtones
en fait c'est comme avant parce que les
communautés autochtones ne sont pas à
montréal enfin très peu également il ya
beaucoup d'autochtones à montréal mais
les communautés sont éloignés donc on
prend le bon vieux téléphone
traditionnel c'est la façon de continuer
à les joindre alors n'y a pas vraiment
de différence en fait je dirais sets
gagnés ont laissé un mari ce virus ne se
comportent pas de la même manière
partout mais chez les premières nations
du canada comment cela se passe en
général est ce qu'il ya des commun
dénominateur commun comment vous le
voyez est à partir de votre travail
justement alors en fait je pense que les
communautés autochtones étaient les plus
inquiètes parce que s'ils virus rang
dans la communauté
ça risque d'être l'hécatombe
heureusement les communautés autochtones
se sont rapidement tournés mesures
d'urgence pour se protéger alors elles
ont vu ce qui arrive est évidemment dans
les grandes il est là ils se sont dit ok
on fermait communauté on se protège
on met en place toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour dépister les gens pour
tester quand on regarde les chiffres
c'est intéressant parce que évidemment
si on les compare à ce qui se passe
ailleurs ils sont ils sont faibles et
heureusement voyez en date du 1er mai ya
des 138 cas de gens qui avaient la copie
19 à travers le pays
au québec par exemple en avant
l'ontario 36 au premier mais y en a 30
au québec ce qui est peu et heureusement
on a vraiment hésité pire ça c'est pour
les premières nations si on regarde le
nunavik donc chez les inuit
il y avait à la mi-avril à peu près en
ce cas le nunavik c'est là la région qui
se trouve au dessus du québec donc le
nunavik appartient au québec il ya des i
know it chez lénine alone avis qu il y
avait une communauté qui a vraiment été
atteintes ces poux vernis tout c'était
une petite communauté un petit village
dit qu'à seulement dans cette communauté
au nunavik sur un total de 11 alors
c'était beaucoup et tout est sous
contrôle
on en a détecté aucun décès jusqu'à
présent alors pour l'instant dans les
communautés autochtones s'en sortent
bien mais j'avoue qu'elle elle marche
sur des oeufs actuellement justement
allez vous demander quels seraient les
principaux défis auxquels sont ou ont
été confrontés les premiers à nassian
canadienne nation autochtone du canada
pendant la pandémie au durant cette
pandémie
il ya beaucoup de défis en réalité parce
que vous savez dans les communautés une
grande pauvreté pour plusieurs
communautés
vous le savez aussi les les autochtones
ont beaucoup d'enfants et donc les
maisons son petit ce sont des maisons
qui ont été données par le gouvernement
qui sont dans les communautés les autres
acteurs ne possède pas de maisons les
maisons appartiennent au conseil de
bande et c'est eux qui distribue donc et
les maisons aux résidents et la
difficulté c'est que souvent ils vivent
a beaucoup ils peuvent être deux trois
mille peuvent être également douzaine
dans une seule maison
alors vous imaginez si le virus entre
dans une maison va évidemment ce sera ce
sera l'épidémie assurée pour tous les
membres de la famille alors ça c'est une
grande difficulté les le manque de
logements
les autochtones ou s'ils ont des défis
aux santé particulier il ya beaucoup de
diabète dans les communautés autochtones
ya beaucoup d' hypertension
il ya beaucoup d'obésité et ça ce sont
trois facteurs importants de décès on
l'a vu dans la coved 19 c'est ça ne
manque pas si on à ces maladies là on
risque de décéder plus que les autres
donc ça c'est un enjeu qui est également
très très important et puis il ya encore
dans beaucoup de communautés autochtones
il ya un manque d'eau potable fait que
vous imaginez quand c'est le temps que
se laver les mains qu'en ces temps ci
lui seul avait les mêmes de l'eau non
potable ça peut encore aller mais on a
besoin d'eau potable pour fonctionner
dans la vie aussi donc ça aussi c'est un
défi qui est majeur je pense qu'à 58
communauté encore à travers le pays qui
n'ont pas d'eau potable et alors ça
amène toutes sortes de d'enjeux donc les
défis sont vraiment imanche et les
communautés autochtones à travers le
pays
al marri la semaine dernière plusieurs
epr est sympa autochtone on dit vouloir
que les décisions concernant le
déconfinement et d'autres décisions en
ce qui concerne la cobi 19,3 au corps en
général soient prises avec les divers
nation rappeler notre responsabilité
correspondant conseil de bande de bandes
pardon les assemblée des premières
nations le gouvernement fédéral et les
gouvernements provinciaux à ce qui
concerne la sécurité la santé des
autochtones au canada et ça c'est pas
évident parce qu'évidemment chez les
autochtones
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont un peu
divisé alors évidemment déjà on sait que
c'est gouvernement fédéral qu'ils gèrent
les communautés les communautés
autochtones à travers la loi sur les
indiens
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
font avec le fédéral et puis il ya quand
même plusieurs trucs qui sont aussi du
côté dans chaque province avec la
province par exemple au québec on à
l'assemblée des premières nations du
québec et du labrador donc c'est un
organisme régional qui a est attaché à
l'assemblée des premières nations du
canada
mais au québec on sait que par exemple
la santé est géré par la province du
québec donc l'assemblée
bien nation québec-labrador doit
s'organiser avec la province du québec
pour régler tout ce qui concerne la
santé
par contre pour d'autres d'autres
sphères d'activité ça se fait avec le
fédéral alors c'est compliqué parce que
ça tout est fragmenté finalement il faut
discuter avec le fédéral pour certains
dossiers il faut discuter avec le
provincial pour d'autres dossiers
en plus il ya la difficulté des
autochtones qui vivent dans les
communautés qui sont à peu près 45 à 50%
mais il ya 55 % des autochtones environ
qui ne vivent pas dans une communauté
donc qui vivent dans des villes dans le
dans des plus petites villes ou des
grandes villes comme montréal
alors pour eux c'est encore autre chose
ils sont pas gérés par par l'assemblée
des premières nations qui sont en dehors
de leur communauté et l'assemblée des
premières nations est là pour gérer ce
qui se passe dans les communautés ce qui
fait que ça devient un peu compliqué
tout ça c'est diviser et évidemment faut
s'organiser après ça pour pour rendre la
vie de tout le monde facile pour ce qui
était du déconfinement l'assemblée des
premières nations du québec labrador
c'est sûr veut avoir le dernier mot
enfin le premier mot à donner quand il
sera question de déconfinement c'est ils
veulent qu'on passe évidemment pour par
eux pour décider est-ce qu'on commence à
les confiner de quelle manière on le
fait mais je pense que les entrées au
québec le gouvernement provincial et est
ouvert à l'idée il ya une bonne
discussion avec avec les premières
nations et avec le chef de l'assemblée
des premières nations du québec et du
labrador du labrador pardon pour
préparer le déconfinement et évidemment
les chaque communauté a son mot à dire
donc la communauté va faire part de ses
besoins qui va l'expliquer à l'assemblée
des premières nations qui valent
d'expliquer au gouvernement du québec
mais les communautés chacune déjà on
vient travailler à ce sujet là pour
protéger leurs membres
anne-marie yvon toujours un plaisir de
parler pour cette journaliste de
l'équipe espaces autochtone de radio
canada
merci pour ce tour d'horizon sur ce qui
arrive en ce qui concerne la pandémie de
lakovic 19 au canada mais
particulièrement dans les communautés
autochtones justement merci beaucoup
merci à l'ovale
[Musique]